it seems that most victories come with a
price
that's no different in the world of
anime for every major victory or reason
to celebrate behind it
is usually a painful decision that a
character has had to make
when you think about it it's the
sacrifice and the journey that makes
seeing light at the end of the tunnel
all the more sweeter right
on that note today we're looking at some
of the most emotional sacrifices in
[Music]
anime
starting off the list is elaine
sacrificed from the seven deadly sins at
tenth place
ban and elaine didn't start out as best
friends the bandit spent a good chunk of
his past seeking the fountain of youth
only to keep getting thwarted by the
fountain's guardian elaine the two
soon develop feelings for each other
though alas happy moments have to win
don't they
a demon attacks the forest and wounds
both ban and elaine and instead of
taking water from the fountain for
herself
elaine makes band drink it granting him
the immortality that he sought
this flashback would surely linger in
the hearts of people who watch the seven
deadly sins for a long long time
[Music]
foreign
jonathan joestar's death from jojo's
bizarre adventure is at number nine on
the list
having believed that he'd put an end to
his nemesis dio jonathan joestar spends
his last moments in phantom blood a
happy and married man
that happiness doesn't last long though
as he gets attacked once more by a still
alive deo during his honeymoon
using the last of his strength he traps
dio and allows his family to escape
as he succumbs to his wounds jonathan
goes out with a smile
having saved his family and forgiving
his worst enemy jonathan's legacy
carries on for the series but even if
the series were to end at this point
he'd already be remembered as an
honorable man who paid the ultimate
price
for the rest of the joestar family
[Music]
we have lucy sacrificing aquarius at the
eighth spot
for most of fairy tale two of lucy's
most trustworthy celestial spirits are
aquarius and leo
in a fight leo is the safer choice as
the water bearer is typically a
temperamental mess
who despite being powerful fights in a
way that causes a lot of trouble to lucy
often out of her own volition however
facing insurmountable odds in the battle
against tartaros
lucy's forced to make the ultimate
sacrifice in order to summon the
celestial spirit king
break aquarius's key despite reaffirming
her disdain for lucy the water bearer
still cries along with her master
taking in the fact that she would never
see lucy again while she retains her
temperamental attitude towards the
celestial spirit mage
aquarius at this final moment reconciles
with her master
only to be shut off from the mortal
realm for good
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
for our seventh moment we have vegeta
blowing himself up in an attempt to take
down majin buu at the time of his
introduction
vegeta was shown to be ruthless and
uncaring he didn't give a damn about
anything but strength
all in all you can see why his eventual
decision to sacrifice himself in the buu
saga is one of the most gripping moments
of that arc
despite not caring about bulma and
trunks it's obvious that the prince of
saiyans is lying and that he's already
completed the character development that
prompts him
to sacrifice himself for the world
vegeta realizes the consequences of all
his previous
actions and decides to blow himself up
going down in a literal blaze of glory
he makes the choice of dying for the
world in an act of personal redemption
[Applause]
me
[Music]
oh
at number six it's rider's doom battle
against gilgamesh from
fate zero if there's a list of all-time
fake anime moments
rider's battle against gilgamesh would
surely make him
this fight has it all glorious noble
phantasms
heartwarming farewell speeches and
gilgamesh finally finding a worthy
opponent
most of all it showcases the fire of
determination burning with invite
assault in one climactic battle
even while finding himself completely
outmatched against the king of heroes
ryder charges on taking everything that
the gate of babylon can toss at him
his sheer will pushes him on but he was
finally put down for good
at the fifth spot we have a sacrificing
his life for luffy
being a storyline revolving around
saving luffy's brother part of the
climax of the marine foot arc ends with
a cloud of despair looming over our
heroes
akainu gets the upper hand on ace and
moves to finish off luffy
it's then the ace steps in and takes the
blow for his brother
one that would ultimately kill him
instead of possibly living on full of
regret ace makes the decision to die in
an act of protecting luffy
he doesn't die in a lost battle against
someone out of his own league but on his
own terms
it could feel unfair especially to one
piece fans but ace's death has a legacy
in it that it finally convinces luffy
that he has to keep getting stronger
[Music]
foreign
irwin smith's sacrifice against the
beast titan ranks fourth on the list
while the commander of the survey corps
did care for his men
he's ruthless and wouldn't hesitate in
sacrificing them for the betterment of
mankind
needless to say the commander is someone
who's caused the deaths of hundreds of
people
soon though he reflects on his actions
and realizes that he's been a hypocrite
all along he's unwilling to die for the
greater cause
while preaching that ideology to justify
his orders and the inner desire that's
fueled by a moment with his father
it's this realization that drives him to
lead the charge against the beast titan
this distraction gives levi the opening
needed to confront and defeat zeke
and in the end it's irwin's desire to
die with the fallen recruits that pushes
levi to save the lethally wounded armin
instead
leaving him to die after a moment of
redemption
[Music]
three we have jiraya giving up his life
in the battle against
payne during his infiltration mission
jiraiya finds himself in the battle
against konam
it turns out that he has his work cut
out not only does he have to contend
with conan he has to fight for his life
against pain
or what's supposed to be pain it's then
that he finds out that pain is actually
an
entity composed of multiple bodies armed
with unique powers
despite his valiant efforts uriah finds
himself overwhelmed by the pains
there's hope at the end of the master
ninja's life he dies not with sadness or
regrets but with a smile
knowing that he's done his part in his
last moments he entrusts the world to
the pupil who he knows would soon carve
his spot in history
as the savior of the world
[Music]
sacrifice at the end of code geass takes
the second spot on the list
still held as one of the most iconic
endings to a legendary series
it would be hard to top lelouch's
sacrifice at the end of code gyas
taking in the hatred of the world and
directing it towards him as an
all-powerful demagogue lelouch finishes
his long-time plan with suzaku by having
suzaku take the guise of zero
and kill him truly a gutsy plan at the
cost
of the greatest sacrifice given
everything else has happened would
anything less have sufficed with the one
focus of hatred gone
lelouch cements himself as a messianic
archetype one who has paid the ultimate
price to save the world
[Music]
oh
me
the number one sacrifice in anime
belongs to isaac naterro
one of the most defining and my personal
favorite battle in chimera ant arc
is the one between chimera and king
meruem and isaac nataro
chairman of the hunter association it's
a battle of two
very powerful characters at peak
performance despite his withered state
and vulnerability after being
overpowered
natero manages to strike fear in
meruem's heart claiming the latter knows
nothing about humanity's endless
potential for evolution and malice
nutero then pierces his own heart with a
finger and detonates the bomb in a last
attempt to put an
end to marowan's reign of terror for
notaro that death is a satisfying one
his long search for a worthy opponent
has finally ended and he was able to
pass away
in peace
so what do you think then guys if you
have any suggestions on some moments
that we've missed
do not hesitate to let your voices be
heard i'll see you next time on vinnie
[Music]
tube
[Music]
um